It's finally here, you guys!
"Game of Thrones" premiered back in the spring of 2011,
and now after eight years,
(twenty-three, if you're a fan of the books)
we are finally getting the answer
we've all been waiting for:
Who will win CLEGANEBOWL?
It's a battle of the Titans!
In one corner, we've got a man who
can crush your head like a Gusher,
and in the other we've got a man
who really likes his chickens.
It's the meme the writers have
reluctantly included for fanservice,
but nevertheless, GET HYPE!
Oh, and I guess we'll also get to find out
who gets to rule Westeros.
So that's cool...
Hello Internet! Welcome to Film Theory!
The show where the night is dark, and full of theories!
You guys, I can't believe that
"Game of Thrones" is nearly over.
I know, I know that we're gonna get
ourselves a variety of spin-offs and whatnot,
But we can never go back to this time
when we were first discovering
a fantasy series that was as rich as Lord of the Rings,
with the added bonus anxiety of thinking
that any character could die at any time.
And at this point, with only six episodes left,
it's impressive that "Game of Thrones" still feels like it could go in any dozen of different directions,
Will John and Daenerys save the world and
become Westeros' hot young power couple?
Will Bran turn out to be the Night King?
Or will Podrick heal the world
with his magical lovemaking?
"These ladies enjoyed him so much
they gave him the time for free?"
No one knows!
Well, no one except for Sansa's friends.
It is probably the single most hyped series finale in TV history since Breaking Bad ended back in 2013.
So much so that there are betting odds
for who will rule Westeros at the end,
as well as who will be first to die in this new season.
Let's just say, looking at the odds,
things aren't looking too hot for the Greyjoys.
And so of course, true to form, today's theory is all about how this whole thing is gonna end.
Now, is my theory today gonna tell you to run to Vegas,
plunk down your cash on Tyrion, Varys and Dany for the win-place-show to get yourself rich?
No, today's theory is about how
Game of Thrones should end,
not about how it will end.
And I think that those are two very different things.
At this point, the narrative of Game of Thrones is constrained by a number of factors.
It's a victim of its own success.
I mean, sure, Game of Thrones isn't
afraid of being dark and ripping fans' hearts out,
but HBO might now be reluctant to do certain things,
now that they want people to stay invested
in "Game of Thrones" spin-off shows.
They might feel like they need a more TV-friendly
ending that leaves people wanting more,
or leave certain characters alive.
Plus, who knows how much the end of the series will line up
with the way that George R.R. Martin
decides to end the books.
I mean if you're Martin, don't you kinda
want the show to end a bit differently,
so that there's still some reason
to read those last two books,
"Winds of Winter", and "A Dream of Spring"
when they eventually come out?
If they eventually come out...
they're never coming out, are they?
So today? I'm talking about the
ending that should happen.
Once you get past all the dragons and war and incest,
What is "Game of Thrones" really about?
And what kind of ending would
serve all those themes the best?
It may not be the ending that Westeros needs,
but it is the ending that Westeros deserves.
As Kate says in her prophecy for Daenerys
"To go forward, you must go back."
So to think about how "Game of Thrones"
should end, let's take a look at how it begins.
The pilot of a show like "Game of Thrones" is important,
because it's likely to establish not just the characters,
and setting, and plot points that
will endure throughout the show,
but also because they tend to hint at the themes and messages
that the show will explore throughout the rest of it's run.
In our inaugural episode, we establish three main houses: Stark, Lannister and Targaryen.
These are the ones that the show
tells us to invest in at the outset,
and while plenty of other houses have become important over the course of the series,
the show, going into its final season,
is still focused on these three.
The Tyrells are dead:
*explosion*
The Boltons are dead:
*dogs eating Ramsay Bolton*
The Martells are dead:
"Your daughter will die here in this cell and you will be here watching"
The Freys are dead:
"Winter came for House Frey."
the Greyjoy's and Tully's are still kicking around,
but, be honest with me, do you really care?
No, every time I hear about the Greyjoys,
my eyes roll into the back of my head.
"What is dead, may never die."
What is dead, may never die?
More like what is dead should stay dead,
and just stick on their own damn island!
They're distractions, they were never
real contenders for the throne.
But not only are the Starks, Lannisters and Targaryens the first three houses we become familiar with,
each one demonstrates a major theme
that ends up pervading the rest of the series
1: The price of power,
2: The failure of man's institutions,
and 3: The dangers of pride.
And by looking at the way the series
explores these themes, and these houses,
we get ourselves a clear pathway to what
should be the ending for the entire series.
Theme number 1: The price of power.
From the earliest days of watching the series,
we may not have been able to tell a Maester Pycelle from a Barristan Selmy,
but one thing we all knew was the Lannister motto:
"A Lannister always..."
"Don't say it!"
"Don't f****** say it."
It was beaten over our head.
With a seemingly limitless amount of money,
they bought their way into power and prestige in Westeros.
They understand the cost of things,
and they understood that sometimes that cost is more than just a bag of gold.
More often than not, the price of their own lofty ambitions was human life.
In the pilot alone,
they poison the hand of the king Jon Arryn,
to prevent him from revealing the fact that Robert's children were in fact Jamie's,
and then they attempt to murder
Bran for discovering the same exact thing.
Whether they're pushing children from windows,
hijacking their enemies weddings,
or blowing up hundreds of people to avoid going to trial,
there is nothing that the Lannisters won't do to remain in charge.
And while the juicy violence is certainly
a part of the reason why we watch the show,
a huge part of the narrative is all about the debts that need to be paid when you take these sorts of actions.
The karma that results from this kind of lust for power.
Tywin Lannister masterminds
the red wedding which kills Catelyn Stark,
only to have Petyr Baelish reciprocate by killing his grandson during the Purple Wedding.
Cersei may solve one problem in blowing up the
Sept of Baelor at the end of season six,
but the karmic retribution she receives is that her last living child Tommen jumps to his death out of grief.
She achieves power, but at the cost of the only thing that truly mattered to her in her life, her children, dying off.
The Lannisters do indeed pay their debts.
And while it's most obvious with the Lannisters,
the price of power is something
that pervades every element of the series.
Stannis is so consumed by his desire to be king that he's willing to murder his brother Renly,
and burn his daughter Shireen.
He still loses and dies.
Daenerys' older brother Viserys arranges to have his sister married off to a bloodthirsty warlord,
just so he can retake the crown.
And in the end Virserys gets his crown,
just not the way he intended.
Even the more honourable quests
for power come with a huge price tag.
Few would argue that Jon Snow
didn't hold the moral high ground,
against Ramsay Bolton during
the Battle of the Bastards,
but the show makes sure that we see
that even justified conquest is awful.
Jon Snow doesn't want thousands of people to die, offering Ramsay a one-on-one duel instead,
but when Ramsay refuses, everyone
on that battlefield ends up dying anyway,
so much so that Jon almost suffocates
to death under a giant pile of corpses.
And then you've got Daenerys,
who genuinely has progressive ideas about abolishing slavery and demolishing class divisions.
But for someone who talks about leaving
the world a better place than she found it,
she sure does love burning people alive.
The moral here is that everyone,
good, bad or otherwise, has blood on their hands.
And sure, while you may be rewarded temporarily,
eventually, you're gonna have to pay your karmic debt.
Theme number two: The failure of institutions.
The thirst for power is a big
element to Game of Thrones to be sure,
but in reality, it's just a symptom of institutions that humans have put into place for themselves.
Part of the reason Daenerys wants
to break the wheel in the first place,
is because the rules about how people
are governed are unjust and lead to abuse.
The system of royal succession, for example,
not only leads to infighting,
but also gives rise to rulers
who have no business ruling.
Joffrey? He cared more about torturing people with crossbows than he did about ruling.
Tommen? He was around 13 when he took the throne.
Heck, even King Baratheon!
I mean sure he was older,
and not a homicidal sociopath,
but he readily admits that he
was a warrior rather than a ruler.
"Lord Eddard Stark, I would name
you the hand of the king."
"I'm not trying to honor you."
"I'm trying to get you to run my kingdom while I eat, drink and whore my way to an early grave."
The fight between Stannis and Renly?
Sure, Stannis had a better claim to the throne as the next oldest brother to the king,
but Renly Was probably the better option.
Having more public support and leadership ability.
The systems devised by men are constantly failing.
The characters know that they're flawed,
but they don't do anything
to fundamentally change the system.
Even Daenerys herself is a part of this problem,
I mean, think about it.
She says that she wants to change everything,
but at the same time she insists that
she's the rightful claim to the throne,
simply because she's the daughter of a former king.
A former king who happened to be a homicidal maniac.
She says she wants to break the wheel,
but apparently she doesn't
want to break the wheel entirely,
she wants to keep intact the parts of the wheel that, you know, support her claim to the throne.
I mean nobody is really advocating
for democracy in Westeros,
so how much are we really
shattering that wheel, friends?
And it's not just political systems either.
Look at another institution that plays
a huge role throughout the story: marriage.
Daenerys, at least in the books,
is a 13 year old who's married off to a warlord.
Sansa's marriage to Tyrion is loveless
and fails to protect her,
her marriage to Ramsay is even worse.
Neither Robert Baratheon nor Cersei is happy in their marriage, even Catelyn and Eddard Stark.
What should be a loving marriage between
two of the show's most noble characters
is tainted by her mistaken belief that he cheated on her,
leading to the birth of Jon Snow,
and her lifelong resentment of him.
The only truly positive love-filled marriage
that we see on screen is with Robb Stark,
and um, that didn't turn out too well either.
So if government and marriage aren't working too well in Westeros, then how about religion?
No again, according to Georgie Martin!
Sure, the Lord of Light may be able to raise people from the dead, and give birth to shadow babies,
but he also requires human sacrifices
in exchange for winning battles,
that, whoops, you end up losing anyway!
Then, there's the entirety of seasons 5 and 6,
when Tommen yields too much
power to the High Sparrow.
It is one of the longest, and, in my opinion,
most frustrating plot lines in the series,
because it feels like filler that just
slogs on for way too long.
But when you actually stop and look at the themes of the entire story of "Game of Thrones",
the purpose actually becomes clear.
It's to show that no one, no institution is truly good.
No matter how pious or noble
the intentions might at first seem.
Which is exactly why the Starks
are so important in the story.
Eddard Stark was a man defined by his belief of the inherent good of human institutions,
and it gets him killed.
His reliance on the arbitrary rules, and the way things are supposed to be done gets him beheaded.
Sansa desires a life of finery
living with the nobles in King's Landing,
but when she finally gets it, she winds up
being abused by Joffrey, and then the Boltons.
It's only when she rejects society's rules for her,
that she regains any sort of power in the story.
Jon Snow is constantly trying to help the Night's Watch help themselves, and their response is to kill him for it.
Now, in the aftermath of the Battle of Hardhome, where the tribe leaders pledged their weapons to him,
he's basically the equivalent of the King-Beyond-the-Wall.
He is a Wildling, and is more successful now than he ever was when he was wearing the black.
But, perhaps the most obvious example is Arya.
At the beginning of the story, Arya
admires her sword master Syrio Forel,
a water dancer with perfect stances and elegant moves.
The Hound quickly disabuses her of this.
"Who taught you that shite?"
"The greatest swordsman who ever lived."
"Alright, you have a sword."
"Let's see what he taught you."
"Your friend's dead."
"Meryn Trant's not,
"because Trant had armour and a big f****** sword."
she then moves on to overturn the organization of the Faceless Men to become a merciless assassin,
following her own rules and taking
on any identity she chooses,
and in the process, she literally
has to reject her identity as a Stark.
"Who are you?"
"No one."
It's only when the Starks deny
their name and their upbringing,
and their house's belief on the safety of institutions,
that they're finally able to survive in this world.
Looking across the series, all the systems
are unjust, unfair and destructive.
Human society fails over and over again,
which leads us to theme
number 3: The dangers of pride.
Potential threats to our beloved characters are telegraphed everywhere in this show.
Catelyn actively warns Robb Stark to stay true to his marriage promise to the Freys,
"Walder Frey is a dangerous man to cross."
"I know that."
"You gave him your word."
"Treat your oaths recklessly,
and your people will do the same."
And he doesn't, and winds up dead.
When Eddard threatens to expose Cersei's adultery,
she turns the threat right back at him.
"When the King returns from his hunt,
I'll tell him the truth."
"Wherever you go, Robert's wrath will follow you.
"And what of my wrath, Lord Stark?"
"When you play the Game of Thrones,
you win, or you die."
He's arrested, and executed.
The slave masters of Meereen are given a pretty sweet deal by Tyrion to take seven years to phase out slavery,
but they're unwilling to cooperate,
and say it with me now,
they get themselves killed.
In all of these cases, and so many more throughout the series, pride is the reason for their downfall.
Robb, and Ned, and the slave masters were so confident that they were untouchable,
that they ignored the warnings.
When Jon Snow returned to Castle Black from his semester abroad with the Wildlings,
he gives the Night's Watch the advice to let the Wildlings through.
They refuse, and most die as a result.
Speaking of Wildlings, let's not forget Mance Rayder,
the King-Beyond-The-Wall, their unofficial ruler.
A man who refuses to bend his knee to anyone else.
That pride costs him his life,
and the lives of many of his followers.
"Mance Rayder was a brave man."
"A proud man."
"Never bent the knee."
"How many of his people died for his pride?"
Pride gets people killed.
It gets them to not cooperate.
It gets them to not listen to each other.
It gets them to ignore the warning signs,
and by the time they realize the danger,
it's too late to do anything about it.
Nowhere is this better exemplified than the last of our three houses: the Targaryens.
Viserys' this time on the show was short-lived,
but it was filled with misplaced pride.
"I am a Khaleesi of the Dothraki!"
"The next time you raise a hand to me,"
"Will be the last time you have hands."
And the would-be Dragon King ignores the warnings,
and earns himself his long overdue golden crown.
Daenerys is equally prideful though,
and pays for it dearly on multiple occasions.
It's actually the entire point of another
of my less than favorite plot lines: Meereen.
In Meereen, she struggles against her pride constantly,
as she tries to rule over slavers Bay.
On one hand, her treatment
of the Masters wins her no favors.
"I've ordered Daario to execute every master in Yunkai."
"Herding the masters into pens, and slaughtering them by the thousands is also treating men like beasts."
"There's good and evil on both sides in every war."
"Slavery is real. I will end those behind it."
But at the same time, she loses the popular vote when she decides to publicly execute her advisor.
*crowd booing*
*axe noise*
*crowd hissing*
And of course, there's the fighting pits.
Despite being advised by others to uphold
this ancient tradition for the good of people,
she thinks she knows better,
refuses to heed the concerns of her team,
and opens the door to more
animosity between her, and the city.
"They did ask for some concessions."
"Concessions."
"Politics is the art of compromise, your grace."
"I'm not a politician, I'm a queen."
"It's easier to rule happy subjects, than angry ones."
In each case, a prideful decision from her comes with heavy negative consequences.
And now, as we race towards the finish of the show,
pride is once again a huge focus around her storylines,
demanding that Jon Snow kneel to her as Queen before she'll lend him any favor.
"I will fight for you, when you bend the knee."
"My people won't accept a southern ruler."
"They chose you to lead them."
"Isn't their survival more important than your pride?"
Here's why all this matters.
Throughout the entirety of the series, everyone has ignored the real threat to Westeros - the White Walkers.
Remember how I said that pilot episodes tend to kick off all your important characters and themes?
Well in the opening minutes of the show, what are we shown?
Not any of the houses, not King's Landing.
Heck, not even characters that
live through the opening moments!
No, we are shown the danger of the White Walkers, as they butcher a scouting party.
Even before that iconic theme music
plays for the first time,
it is the White Walkers that are getting top billing.
Later on that same episode, we see Ned
make his first crucial decision of the series,
and by extension, his first crucial mistake of the series.
He has to choose what to do with the deserter who escaped the White Walker attack with his life.
Ned, being a man of rules and institutions, decides to behead him,
despite the boy's warnings of the White Walker threat.
"I know I broke my oath."
"I saw what I saw."
"I saw the White Walkers."
"People need to know."
"Is it true he saw the White Walkers?"
"The White Walkers have been gone for thousands of years."
And from that point forward, everyone
just ignores the ice zombie threat.
Shortly after Eddard's beheading,
Alistair Thorn is sent to King's Landing with a zombie hand to show off, and no one cares.
The Nights Watch meanwhile, is sending out dozens of messages to all the houses asking for help,
and all of the messages get ignored for months.
Samwell Tarly tells the Maesters in The Citadel that he has actually seen these things and that the threat is real,
and they choose to just sit on their hands.
Winter was coming, and coming, and still coming,
and took a really long time to get there,
but no one cared.
No one prepared.
They fought petty little battles against each other, sacrificing thousands of lives,
just to decide who got to sit on
a really uncomfortable looking chair,
and now, the karmic debt is coming due.
In the final hours, Cersei sees
an undead Wight point blank,
and her pride prevents her from
partnering with rivals to the throne.
"In return, the King in the North will extend this truce."
"He will remain in the North where he belongs."
"I cannot give you what you ask."
"I cannot serve two Queens."
"Then there is nothing left to discuss."
"The dead will come North first."
"Enjoy dealing with them."
"We will deal with whatever is left of you."
If this show has taught us anything,
it's that everyone tends to die
when people don't cooperate.
So what kind of ending best fits with what Game of Thrones is trying to tell us?
How should Game of Thrones end?
Well, if we're looking at it from
a purely thematic standpoint,
the White Walkers should wipe out everyone.
Mankind hasn't learned it's lesson.
We either work together to all survive,
or we all end up dying.
People continue to be disloyal, brutal, willfully ignorant.
They rely on systems that lead to abuse.
They're prideful, and that pride
prevents them from working together.
So who deserves to rule Westeros?
No one.
I mean sure, Daenerys and John
are working together now,
but it's a little too little too late.
They're all too self-interested,
too short-sighted,
too ethically compromised.
The ending that makes the most thematic sense for Game of Thrones is for the White Walkers to win.
For society to reset, in some way.
It's not that mankind should lose,
because Game of Thrones is some nihilistic
universe in which choices don't matter,
it's the complete opposite.
It's that the choices mankind
made in the lead-up to winter were wrong.
They made the wrong choices.
They weren't the responsible ones.
And in the end, those choices should
lead to their ultimate downfall.
And if you don't believe that
this is the ending that's deserved,
remember, it's mankind's fault
that the White Walkers exist in the first place.
In the Season 4 finale episode 'The Children',
Bran learns that the White Walkers were created by the Children of the Forest thousands of years ago,
but the reason they created them was to defend against the destructive force
that was invading Westeros - the first men.
Men landed in Westeros, and immediately began slaughtering the indigenous races.
In this way, the fall of Westeros
is as much karma as it is anything else!
There would be a karmic debt
to pay for mankind's brutality.
For their unjust systems to be wiped out.
For their inability to cooperate leading to their demise,
at the hands of a unified singular White Walker force, that wouldn't exist if it wasn't for them.
One that the show's creators decided to show us,
before we met any other characters in the series.
What makes the most sense is
for winter to come for all mankind.
Will my prediction come true?
Well, it's hard to spin off a series
when everyone's dead, so probably not.
But you gotta admit, that would be one really memorable way to end a series.
But hey, that's just a theory - a Film Theory!
Aaaand cut!